for whatever it's worth badger here
what I'm a circus has to be better I'm
just saying
that we found a job I'm not hugging you
guys ready or what
hopefully you had a chance to watch most
or all of defenders by now we will be
talking about pretty much everything but
they reveal most of the big twists about
where the hand came from what their
ultimate goal is how they're using all
this Iron Fist mythology to tie
everything together in the Marvel
Netflix universe this wasn't intended to
be too much of a review video but I will
say that they have about four episodes
worth of content and story that they
stretch out into a DEP Asst odes which
is kind of what they did with Iron Fist
they kind of did that with Luke Cage as
well so that seems to be a running theme
with the Netflix shows so hopefully they
can fix some of that when they get to
the next seasons but I think they're
tuning things as they go along I've
already done that video about the actual
end tag with daredevil so I'll post a
link to that at the end of this but as
for the final fate of the five fingers
of the hand they said that this was
intended to be the wrap-up of their
storylines so they introduced them
during daredevil season two then we met
a couple more fingers of the hand during
iron fist so they basically want to get
rid of the hand is a villain in the
Marvel Netflix universe that was the
point in killing or making it seem like
all these members were dead so if it
wasn't clear at the end of the series
the door that they're trying to get iron
fist to open is a door that sort of
connects them to Kunlun with the
skeletons of dead dragons like Shou Lao
they imply that during their first life
in ancient times there used to be many
many dragons we're just seeing the
skeleton of one in particular and they
make it seem like it's the skeleton of
Shou Lao but Madame Gao is the one that
says the Dragons used to roam the skies
so it just means that there used to be a
lot of dragons Shou Lao was the one that
Iron Fist got his powers from just like
in the comics so the whole idea is that
this is all this Iron Fist mythology
that they're blending with daredevil in
the hand because in the comics the hand
is a completely different group they
have completely different origins so to
explain the origin of the hand in the
defenders universe you have five people
that originally traveled to Kunlun when
they had first started to study chi in
the nature of life so as the monks learn
to harness this power you have five
people who want to use the power to live
forever they leave and become the five
fingers of the hand they don't say
exactly what the date was when they left
conlon or where they all come from
specifically because they all looked
like they came from around the world
but I think because they all came from
cultures that had developed to a certain
point you can assume that there are
thousands of years old but not tens of
thousands of years old
one of the really good examples is
Alexandre referencing the dish of food
that she ate in Constantinople that they
make for her in the restaurant oh it's
just as good is when I ate it in
Constantinople that city was founded in
330 ad so let's just say she's a couple
thousand years old and she's just been
regenerating over and over this time
like death has not been a big deal for
them because we learned that the liquid
that they dip people in is actually made
from the ground-up bits of the dragon
bones so the idea that they're mining
the material they don't say exactly what
it is it's material taken from the
fossilized remains of the Dragons so
they're literally cannibalizing the
Dragons to live forever that's the whole
idea there are some demons in the comics
that do this they try to eat shall
allows dragon egg when it's still
getting ready to hatch so in the comics
the hand doesn't do any of this there's
no big crossover with Kunlun there is a
fraction storyline where the hand does
try to infiltrate Kunlun but that's
about it
in the comics the hand actually starts
out in the daredevil comics the five
fingers of the hand represent the five
islands of Japan so their origin is
based much more in the real world but
because the Netflix Universe wanted to
bring this all together they just
decided to tie them to the Iron Fist
mythology so it's a bit of a big change
there but the other big change is that
the hand in the comics also worships a
demon like they literally call it the
demon it gives them special powers and
they try to find a vessel so that it can
re-enter the world so a big daredevil
arc is called shadow land where
daredevil literally gets infused with
the demon so they could say the devil of
Hell's Kitchen
so for a time he becomes possessed with
the demon it looks like an actual devil
so the metaphor becomes reality so when
people talk about the black sky and
Elektra that's kind of where we thought
they were going they're like oh okay
Elektra is going to be the vessel for
the demon that they try to resurrect
nope they're not doing any of that but
if they have mystical dragons maybe
they'll eventually get to demons too but
the way they're making it sound the big
villain of the next defenders team-up
will probably wind up being the kingpin
because it sounds like they're going
with more real-world villains I think
they have a couple
problems with the iron fist mythology
right now like think about all the times
that iron fist was trying to explain his
origin to Luke Cage and he's like he
just scoffs at it like that's not real
I'd rather face a dragon than Jessica
Jones any day and it just sounds weird
coming out of iron fist mouth yeah won't
you tell me again about how you punched
the dragon and got your magic hand
during the final trial of shall allow
the undying I plunged my fist into his
ball do mark I was kidding
I'm from Kunlun I plunged my hands into
the heart of a dragon that's where I got
my power from and Luke Cage laughs at
him we're kind of the audience in that
moment too just because it sounds so
ridiculous even though if you've read
the comics that's exactly how he gets
his power so I think it was brilliant in
using iron fist is the MacGuffin of the
season he's the most powerful character
in the universe he just doesn't know it
yet like he's only halfway to being the
full version of iron fist he can't light
up both of his hands yet and in the
comics he can actually light up his
entire body crazy Opie so he will be the
most powerful person in this universe
once he gets his [ __ ] together but one
of the funny things about the defenders
series is that Alexandra horny Weaver is
fantastic in the role even though
sometimes her motivations aren't always
clear she's just afraid of death she
never wants to see that black space
again where she's talking to Elektra our
goal is to never have to see that again
but the other members of the hand sort
of admit we don't care about that we
just want to go home to Conlon we're
tired of this existence we want to go
home to die it sounds like most of them
have made their peace with death in its
really Alexander that's freaking out
over the idea like that's why they have
that extended sequence at the beginning
of the series where she's getting
examined they're like hey all of your
organs are failing your entire body is
shutting down
but hopefully that explains a little bit
about the hands origins in the Netflix
universe and what they were trying to do
that's why I feel like there was a lot
of disappointment with the ending
because you know they opened the door
and you expect to see Kunlun or some big
fantastic thing and it's just a small
cave with a dragon skeleton that they
then collapsed the building on top of
and that's the end of it so it's like
wait a minute
they were just trying to open the door
they just want to go home they have this
giant worldwide organization
and all they want to do is go home so
yes I will say that's a little bit lame
and some of their motivations were know
is clear it didn't always feel
completely consistent but the thing is
is that Defenders was planned out
way back when Netflix first ordered
daredevil season 1 they ordered 60
episodes from Marvel and that was
intended to be the original four series
and then the defenders team-up they
didn't plan for Punisher originally but
since that time said you know they've
completed phase one of defenders they've
already ordered 75 more episodes so
that's basically one more season from
everybody in addition to a season of The
Punisher so that's probably what will
happen and what you'll see in the way
that they started the hand out during
daredevil is that you'll see the big
villain which I think is going to be the
kingpin for Phase two you'll see him
rise during daredevil season 3 and
becomes the big bad of defenders round 2
then when they get to phase 3 they'll
introduce another villain it'll be a
slow burn across all four series but the
other big change too is now we're seeing
more crossover with the characters to
each other series of Jessica Jones on
Luke Cage vice versa
daredevil popping up on Jessica Jones
season 2 maybe and everybody wants to
know about the Punisher crossing over so
I think after the first season of every
show all bets are off it's a little bit
easier once they're established so it
sounds like Punisher will largely be
self-contained Karen page is confirmed a
crossover and like misty night was
confirmed for iron fist season 2 for
everybody that's hoping for daughters of
the Dragon with her Bionic stark tech
arm they have all this really awesome
stuff going for them all the actors are
fantastic even Finn Jones is actually
doing much better as iron fist so
whatever was going on behind the scenes
with that that sounds like it'll be a
lot better during season 2 but it
definitely feels like they're having
problems with the serialized story
because when you serialize things like
this you burn through plot much much
faster than you would in a normal
Network TV show and it might be the case
that the writers are coming from network
television so they're just not used to
burning through this much story this
quickly so hopefully they'll tune things
better for future seasons so Netflix has
data that says that people prefer to see
Iron Fist with Luke Cage so hopefully
they'll listen to that and they'll make
a Heroes for Hire TV series but let me
know in the comments what we
general feelings on defenders I feel
like daredevil was still probably the
strongest character Jessica Jones was
great as comedic relief just commenting
on all the ridiculous stuff that was
happening you look like an [ __ ]
scarf scarf looked better nice ears
their horns they haven't dropped another
Punisher trailer recently but I will add
links for that in the description
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Ashutosh please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details what will
happen next is there'll be some more DC
some more defenders Easter eggs and more
Game of Thrones this weekend so while
you wait for everything you can click
here for that daredevil season 3 teaser
trailer and you can click here for
brand-new Game of Thrones thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight